bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur
[Musique]
sociologos dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler un peu de mon
expérience en doctorat à travers trois
échecs qui ont marqué mon doctorat en
fait une thèse c'est vraiment marqué par
des hauts et des bas on passe par
beaucoup d'émotions c'est un peu
l'ascenseur émotionnel au quotidien et
tout simplement on se retrouve très
fréquemment dans des situations
d'évaluation donc je trouvais que
c'était intéressant aussi de ne pas
idéaliser le doctorat de vous montrer
que on peut vivre des difficultés en
doctorat évidemment mais aussi de
montrer que les échecs ne veulent pas
dire que tout s'arrête j'ai vécu
plusieurs échecs en doctorat comme je
vous le disais aujourd'hui je vais me
concentrer sur trois échecs qui ont
marqué mon parcours doctoral et je vais
vous expliquer ce qui s'est passé et
comment je me suis relevée de ces échecs
et puis ce que je vais faire c'est que
je publierai bientôt une seconde vidéo
dans laquelle je vous présenterai mes
trois plus grandes réussites en doctorat
c'est donc parti pour le premier échec
qui a marqué mon doctorat donc
évidemment le premier échec qui a marqué
mon parcours doctoral et bien c'est
celui qui est arrivé avant même que mon
parcours doctoral ne commence vraiment
c'est-à-dire tout simplement le fait de
ne pas avoir obtenu de contrat doctoral
le contrat doctoral c'est un contrat de
travail qu'on passe avec une université
qui va nous embaucher pour faire notre
thèse c'est le mode de financement de
thèse qui est le plus confortable et
donc malgré 5 C candidatures pour donc
cinq contrats doctoraux différents dans
cinq institutions différentes et bien je
n'ai pas obtenu de contrat doctoral donc
déjà il faut savoir que les procédures
pour obtenir un contrat doctoral elles
sont très différentes en fonction des
universités moi dans mon cas les cinq
contrats pour lesquels j'ai postulé
impliquaient quand même un processus de
sélection assez rigoureux avec des
dossiers à écrire qui sont assez lourds
j'ai passé quand même dans la PL des cas
plusieurs étapes on demande ensuite de
faire un oral devant un jury qui est ma
fois assez impressionnant donc on
s'investit beaucoup émotionnellement en
tout cas moi je me suis beaucoup investi
émotionnellement et j'ai vécu cinq fois
l'espoir le stress de passer devant un
jury et cetera et CIN fois une réponse
négative je vais pas vous mentir c'était
vraiment à chaque fois assez difficile à
encaisser parce que bah tout simplement
on se projette en fait dans l'avenir et
ça vient nous mettre un coup d'arrêt
c'est dur de se dire qu'on est jugé à
100 % sur juste un pro en fait c'est dur
de ne pas se sentir jugé soi c'est pour
ça que c'est peut-être dur à accepter
aussi c'est que on arrive avec un projet
qui nous tient vraiment à cœur c'est
presque un projet de vie qu'on présente
quand en tout cas moi quand j'ai
présenté mon projet de thèse je me
projetais sur 3 qu ans ma vie allait
changer avec ce contrat doctoral que
c'est vrai que c'est assez dur de se
dire que c'est un exercice de style déjà
d'une part et que on est jugé sur un
projet qui doit rentrer dans un cadre
universitaire avec certaines consignes
et je pense que que moi je me suis quand
même senti à un moment jugé sur ma
personne c'est pour ça que j'ai eu
autant de mal à l'encaisser je pense
pour moi ce qui était super important ça
a été la partie où j'ai essayé
d'objectiver les refus c'est-à-dire de
comprendre et d'admettre déjà que on
juge un dossier et pas une personne et
en plus l'autre chose qu'il m'a fallu
accepter et qui là a été un peu plus dur
pour moi c'est que et bien ce processus
de recrutement il n'est pas guidé à 100
% par la méritocratie par la qualité des
projets de manière objective et cetera
et j'ai réalisé ça quand j'ai pris
conscience qu'on avait tous des projets
thèses extrêmement différents et qui me
semblaiit quand même assez difficile de
comparer des choses qui n'étaient pas
comparables tout simplement j'ai dû
accepter la réalité qui est que il y a
certains sujets qui sont plus
intéressant à un moment donné pour une
école doctorale pour université pour un
laboratoire alors que d'autres sujets
dans la manière dont son présenté en
tout cas sont moins attirants
représentent moins un caractère un peu
innovant en tout cas dans ce qu'on
montre à ce moment-là et du coup on
convain moins et ça en fait c'est très
dur de se rendre compte quand on n'est
pas déjà dans les circuits universitaire
qu'on a pas conscience du fonctionnement
d'un laboratoire ou d'une école
doctorale et c'est vrai que moi quand
j'ai déposé mes dossiers j'avais une
connaissance extrêmement limité de
comment fonctionne un labo comment
fonctionne la recherche en fait j'avais
une expérience d'étudiante mais pas du
tout dans la recherche que je naviguais
à vue et j'ai un peu été naïve dans la
manière de construire mon projet de le
présenter en le construisant juste comme
une bonne élève en fait M de rien il
faut être stratégique et l'autre chose
qui là encore plus dur à accepter pour
moi c'est que évidemment il y a des
intérêts politiques et sociaux dans
l'attribution des contrats doctoraux
tout simplement il y a très peu de
contrats doctoraux et donc c'est le jeu
des relations qui imprègne beaucoup de
milieu moi c'est vrai que j'ai vraiment
eu la naïveté de croire en la
méritocratie de l'université française
alors que j'ai fait un doctor en
sociologie donc c'est quand même le
comble mais voilà on a toujours espoir
en fait de se dire que c'est un milieu
qui valorise l'excellence universitaire
le travail et cetera mais il y a pas que
ça ce qui est en fait le fait de tous
les milieux professionnels je pense mais
voilà donc c'était un échec bah tout
simplement parce que financièrement je
ne pouvais pas entrer en thèse sans
contrat doctoral donc j'ai dû repousser
à 2 ans après mon après mon diplôme de
Master mon entrée en doctorat évidemment
j'aurais vraiment préféré avoir un
contrat doctoral parce que bah on est
toujours mieux quand on a un salaire qui
tombe tous les mois et qu'on a vraiment
100 % de son temps professionnel à dédié
à sa thèse donc ça c'est vraiment
évident que j'aurais préféré avoir un
contrat doctoral mais j'ai dû faire un
plan en fait j'ai dû réfléchir à comment
j'allais me financer j'ai pris un emploi
saisonnier puis un autre ensuite j'ai
travaillé pendant un an dans une
entreprise et en fait je suis entrée en
doctorat en étant déterminé j'avais
vraiment envie de faire ma thèse j'étais
très déterminée j'avais trouvé un moyen
de financer le début de ma thèse du coup
j'étais prête je me sentais prête je me
sentais d'attaque je savais que je
voulais pas retourner dans le milieu de
l'entreprise donc j'étais prête à tout
donner pour ma thèse je pense que c'est
ça qui me fait tenir aussi dans des
conditions qui honnêtement sont pas
faciles je travaille pour pouvoir faire
une thèse alors que certains sont payés
pour pouvoir faire une thèse et on est
jugé pareil à la fin c'est quelque chose
qui peut être hyper dur
psychologiquement à certains moment
pense que j'aurais pas tenu si j'avais
pas la conviction de pourquoi je fais
ces choseslà et si j'étais pas vraiment
déterminé au moment où je suis rentrée
en thèse en ayant en fait conscience de
tout ce dans quoi je me lançais de
pourquoi je faisais de pourquoi c'est
important pour moi à l'échelle de ma vie
j'aurais pas tenu donc voilà alors le
deuxème échec qui a marqué mon parcours
doctoral et bien c'est le jour où on m'a
refusé le poste d'enseignement de mes
rêves on vit beaucoup de refus quand on
est en thèse encore plus quand on a un
thèse non financé parce que on candidate
sans cesse pour obtenir des financements
et cetera et bah 85 % du temps si ce
n'est 95 on obtient des refus en tout
cas j'obtiens des refus mais il y a un
refus qui que j'ai vraiment vécu comme
un échec en fait je venais de finir bah
mon mon financement donc j'ai ça faisait
2 mois que j'étais sans financement et
ça faisait de mois que je savais qu'un
poste allait s'ouvrir dans une
université comme je dois financer ma
thèse et bien c'était pour moi les la
meilleure manière de la financer
c'estàdire que j'allais enseigner dans
une bonne université une université
reconnue quielle ajouté une belle ligne
sur mon CV le salaire était bien euh
voilà c'est un poste qui m'offrait aussi
une stabilité
administrative financière un contrat de
travail voilà ça paraît pas grandchose
comme ça mais je disais souvent à mes
amis que ça allait changer ma vie et que
surtout ça allait déterminer si jeue en
tèse ou pas et c'est là où j'ai fait une
erreur c'est que j'ai tout misé sur ce
poste dans le sens où je pensais être la
candidate parfaite du fait de plusieurs
éléments de mon parcours j'ai mis toutes
les chances de mon côté j'ai été
intervenir dans un cours dans cette
université é j'ai rencontré du monde
là-bas j'ai coorganisé un événement avec
cette université et cetera j'envoie ma
candidature et je reçois quelques
semaines après un mail qui m'annonce qu'
que mon dossier est refusé sans
explication et cetera et là je suis
vraiment déçu j'envoie un mail dans la
foulée pour savoir si je peux connaître
les raisons du refus et on ne me répond
jamais ça m'a fait un choc parce que je
pensais que j'avais un peu appris ma
leçon qui est que il y a des choses en
dehors de mon contrôle qui peuvent
influer sur une décision j'ai fait
l'erreur de me dire que j'avais tout
donné et que il fallait que ça marche
parce que c'était la meilleure option
pour moi donc en plus de ça j'ai mis
vraiment tous mes œufs dans le même
panier en me disant c'est ça qui va
faire que ma thèse va pouvoir continuer
sans ça je continue pas et du coup le
refus il a été difficile à encaisser
parce que je m'étais dit c'est ça ou
rien et on peut pas fonctionner comme ça
quand c'est quand la décision est en
dehors de notre portée voilà j'aurais dû
prévoir plus de plan B C D E F ce que je
fais tout le temps d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment une telle opportunité que j'y
ai cru je me suis projeté à fond ce qui
est bien j'aurais dû continuer à
regarder ailleurs à me dire que ça
pouvait ne pas marcher parce que bah
forcément j'ai été déçu voilà je pense
que c'est vraiment un échec que qui m'a
fait réaliser ça aussi que je dois
toujours être sur mes gardes c'est
triste à dire mais financièrement et
cetera toujours cand à plusieurs choses
envisager plusieurs éventualités en fait
ne jamais se dire c'est tout noir ou
tout blanc et du coup le troisième échec
que j'ai vécu pendant mon doctorat ça a
été un moment où j'ai fait un ascenseur
émotionnel quand à la publication d'un
article donc quand on est doctorant
c'est très important de publier quelques
articles avant notre soutenance donc des
articles universitaires donc dans des
revues scientifiques on a pas mal de
pression là-dessus et c'est assez
délicat parce que on on est bah
forcément au début de notre parcours de
recherche avec des données assez
fraîches on n'est pas sûr de nous nous
et donc au moment où on commence à
prendre confiance et bien faut se
dépêcher de publier parce que le
processus de publication est assez long
moi jusque là j'avais jamais senti ce
cet élan de me dire allez j'envoie une
proposition à telle revue sauf que un
beau jour je vois passer une annonce
pour une revue scientifique mais qui
fait de la vulgarisation scientifique
c'est des articles qui sont un peu plus
courts qui mobiliseent un peu moins de
de littérature qu'un article universaire
classique mais qui reste une très bonne
revue reconnue dans le milieu
scientifique et cetera en plus c'était
une revue anglophone donc moi je me dis
que c'était super pour valoriser ma
recherche et le thème du prochain numéro
était vraiment un thème que j'étais en
train de développer dans ma tête j'en
parle à mes amis doctorantes qui me
motivent à envoyer quelque chose
j'envoie une proposition et là ma
proposition est acceptée je n'en reviens
pas je suis super contente je commence
déjà à parler du fait que je vais
publier à des gens dans mon entour
tourage universitaire et cetera erreur
d'ailleurs je ne parlerai plus jamais de
projet tant que je ne les ai pas fait la
proposition est acceptée et on m'annonce
que j'ai une semaine 3 mois pour envoyer
la version complète de mon article si
vous voulez la proposition d'article
c'est un paragraphe ça doit faire une
demi-page à tout casser et là on demande
d'envoyer un article de trois pages donc
ce qui est pas énorme pour un article
universitaire mais qui en fait est quand
même long à écrire et justement écrire
quelque chose de court c'est parfois
plus complexe et donc on me demande
d'écrire cet article de trois pages en
une semaine là je me mets à fond en plus
c'est en anglais donc c'est quand même
un petit challenge de plus moi j'ai
jamais écrit d'article universitaire
donc j'ai pas ce côté écriture
automatique où je connais les codes et
tout donc je vais déjà lire d'autres
articles qui ont été publiés dans cette
revue j'écris plusieurs versions je me
fais relire par des anglophone j'envoie
mon article à temps normalement ce qui
se passe à partir de ce moment-là c'est
que notre article est lu par au moins
deux chercheurs qui sont anonymes donc
c'est un procédé qu'on appelle la
relecture à double aveugle donc je SAV
sa que mon article allait devoir passer
par cette étape et ensuite on nous
envoie les retours des experts qui nous
indiqueent s'il y a des corrections
mineur à effectuer des corrections
majeures à effectuer ou si l'article est
tellement loin de la proposition
initiale ou bien qu'il y a des fautes
très graves dans la méthodologie ou dans
Lapp théorique qu'on doit le refuser
donc j'attends patiemment le retour des
correcteurs et je reçois en fait un mail
qui m'annonce que finalement mon article
ne sera pas considéré par les corrects
donc honnêtement quand je reçois ce mail
je me dis que j'ai dû écrire vraiment un
truc horrible mon premier réflexe c'est
de me remettre en question de me dire
que mon article était nul et ensuite
j'en ai parlé à mes amis doctorantes qui
m'ont dit mais en fait c'est un peu
bizarre parce que après une proposition
normalement on refuse pas un article
comme ça et surtout il était noté dans
le mail que mon article n'avait pas été
soumis à la relcture à double augle que
en fait mon article n'avait même pas été
envoyé au relecteur et du coup j'ai
demandé par retour de mail à obtenir les
raisons de de ce refus et la réponse que
j'ai reçu m'a laissé un peu pantise
puisque il m'a été dit que l'article ne
correspondait pas à la ligne éditoriale
de la revue ce qui ne faisait pas trop
sens puisque ma proposition d'article
avait été reçue et que j'étais restée
dans la ligne exacte de ma proposition
d'article il y a plein d'explications
possibles je ne peux pas savoir je ne
saurai jamais je n'ai pas obtenu de
réponse et j'ai fait la paix avec ça ce
que j'ai réalisé c'est aussi que je
m'étais peut-être un peu précipité dans
la publication de ces données là qui en
fait maintenant je réalise sont des
données qui vont peut-être être au cœur
d'un chapitre entier de ma thèse je sais
que c'est des données qui sont
importantes je commence à comprendre
leur valeur leur intérêt théorique la
manière dont elles peuvent contribuer à
ma discipline et je me dis qu'en
publiant ces données et bien j'aurais un
peu gâché entre guillemets mes données
je me dis que c'est pas plus mal que
j'ai pris un peu de recul sur ces
données que j'ai laissé le temps au temp
et je me dis que j'aurais en fait cédé à
la pression qu'on a à publieré en
publiant quelque chose qui n'était pas
vraiment qualitatif alors que M
maintenant je me sens beaucoup plus
capable de publier un article
intéressant à partir de ces données là
mais voilà ça était un un échec qui a
était dur à encaisser là encore un refus
comme il y en a tant d'autres finalement
dans un parcours de doctorante voilà
donc pour les trois échecs qui ont
marqué mon parcours doctoral jusqu'à
présent ce que je voulais c'était
surtout vous montrer que un parcours
doctoral c'est pas du tout linéaire mais
surtout que en fait un échec n'est pas
une fatalité d'ailleurs je vous retrouve
très bientôt pour la deuxème partie de
cette vidéo qui sera à propos de mes
trois plus belles réussites depuis le
début de mon doctorat merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à la chaîne à liker la vidéo à
la partager et à faire vivre sociologos
je vous dis à bientôt sur
[Musique]
sociologos